los resultados de las elecciones en
líbano ya se dieron a conocer y auguran
un cambio significativo en el equilibrio
de poder el grupo hezbollah apoyado por
irán y sus aliados obtuvo 62 escaños en
la asamblea de 128 plazas no alcanzaron
los 65 necesarios para mantener la
mayoría en el parlament o un vuelco para
la facción chiíta que mantuvo el apoyo
mayoritario desde 2018 sus oponentes más
fuertes en el parlamento estarán
liderados por el partido cristiano
alineado con arabia saudita conocido
como fuerzas libanesas que realizó una
feroz campaña contra hezbollah la
frustración del país contra el status
quo impulsó a los grupos políticos
reformistas que surgieron de las
manifestaciones de 2019 ganando al menos
13 escaños mientras que los candidatos
antisistema obtuvieron 16 un salto
significativo para ambos en comparación
con las elecciones de 2018 la votación
del domingo registró una baja
participación de poco más del 40 por
ciento y se vio empañada por acusaciones
de fraude electoral algunos reformistas
acusaron a los partidos tradicionales de
intentar invalidar algunos votos de la
diáspora en los que habían depositado
sus esperanzas
el ministro de interior ha negado las
acusaciones
y falsificación ve usted falsificación
en estos resultados hemos supervisado el
proceso electoral adecuadamente y los
jueces han hecho su trabajo no
interferimos en los resultados
las elecciones generales son las
primeras desde el colapso financiero del
líbano y la mortal explosión del puerto
de beirut en 2020 que hizo que la
economía cayera en picada y agudizó el
enfado de la población contra la
corrupta élite gobernante